the cross section of a trough that is l
meters long okay let's put some
information on here l meters where's
that that's the trophic tell meters long
the cross section is in the shape of an
isosceles triangle of base measurement
to a beaters sorry and where did I lose
my face height be meters okay so we got
this desert mm-hmm by the rate at which
the water level is sorry i missed the
sentence water leaks from the trough at
a constant rate of C meters cubed per
kid
okay they're good now I have a diagram
find the rate at which the water level
is falling when the depth of the water
is beyond two meters okay great so
there's your little setup now this is
not something i did in previous
questions part in a question like this
it's very very helpful to us everything
that I've just said everything the
question is just provided to us right
how many of them can change how many of
these quantities can change I draw it
400 how many of my answer is none of
them can change none of these ones can
change anyway because what are they they
describe the physical dimensions of this
trough and we're not expecting it's a
magic word trough that can just you know
change its shape it's a shape-shifting
trough you know it's not one of those
it's just going to stay those dimensions
and you've got this up water leaking out
here but that's constant none of these
things are variables okay so therefore
I'm actually just going to a other top
right-hand corner of where I'm doing my
working I'm going to label those as
constants now in previous questions we
haven't done this partly because they're
just haven't been that many clusters
flying around for instance they'll give
you a number they'll say it's 10 meters
long and they'll say it's this wire than
that tall and we don't need to usually
think oh it's Ted a constant or a
variable you know it's a closer right
here they have all these Pro new rules
and it can be very easy to confuse which
ones I'm actually sorry did I just say
there's lots of pro two rules that right
well some of them are going to be
variables but these ones are going to be
constant so I'm going to take note of
that okay I've got an a b c and what was
it l there you go okay great now what
was the question find the rate at which
the water level is falling when the
depth of water is beyond 2 meters okay
now there's something that's changing
here right but all of these things are
constant so i'm going to introduce some
language here i need to introduce some
variables right so let me put some water
in this
thud aah I have water okay let's make a
transfer truck shall we we've got some
water boil over okay so there's some
water in there that water's going to
have a volume it's going to have a depth
right so let's start to talk about that
that kind of stuff let's say let V be
the water volume now they talk about
depth but I try as much as I can even
though it's not always possible I try as
much as I can to avoid having a variable
called lowercase D because then you get
DeeDee on whatever okay now honestly
it's going to happen to you sometimes
okay so you can't always avoid it
sometimes they say let this equal Dean
say I just okay but let's try and avoid
it so instead of talking about depth
I've got water volume let's talk about
hi shall we HB the water fight or death
they're the same thing in this constant
context okay now V me the water volume
HP the water height after and I want a
time variable in here right because
these two things unlike these guys these
two are changing right so after tea now
what unit should we choose to time screw
it the same one that they given you will
always have that luxury sometimes the
units in time are going to mix up you
have to be very very cautious about this
but thankfully the only thing that's
dependent on tied right here is the
water leaking they provided a unit so it
might as well stick with it okay good
now having just introduced all of these
in the same vein as i did this i'm going
to say variables and I said vh2 follow
height time great now have you phrased
the question in this language okay what
is it that I'm actually trying to find
out I'll read the question again find
the rate at which the water level is
falling when the depth of water is
beyond two so what expression or what
equation by trying to solve what am I
for the rare which the water level is
falling how would you write that that
would be D age a change in the height
over time it's going to be some told me
this isn't it's gonna be some meters per
minute okay now therefore if I want but
this is what I want okay d.h on dt i'm
going to need to put that in terms of
the other information that i have ok
well there's oh there's another rate in
here which we've been given right what
rate from this diagram do we know we
know the constant C don't we loser is
leaking at sea cubic meters per minute
ok so therefore i can make a statement
about what derivative dvo GT is it
getting bigger or is it getting smaller
it's reducing is it because what is
coming out ok so therefore it should be
negative it's decreasing and it's just
equal to that constant they do see ok
now it's nice to have to be on duty
because that means we have something on
dt here ok so therefore when i tried to
find this i'm going to use chain rule
our time what should I right over here
in the right hand time I want to write I
suppose you to rein in whatever order
you like could product is a bit but I
tend to like having deal with you on the
top first I want a d h on the top right
and I already know I've got DV or DTS at
the bottom ok so clearly i'm going to
need this derivative here ok so if i can
solve for D H on TV or DB on the agent
really the same thing upside down then
I'm basically sorted that makes it okay
No therefore to try and work out this I
will need a relationship between V and H
a relationship between V H ok so maybe I
should put H on my diagram
there it is okay so how will i form a
relationship between V and H so that I
can differentiate it a relationship
means I again what I want right so well
i'm trying to say i want this that's why
i write this i want V right as a
function of H does that make sense of it
I can differentiate yeah what would vb
as a function of right now what do i
need to work out the volume of the water
in the tank right trough sorry okay well
I need height but there's another
measure my knees isn't there I need to
know that the base be a funny calling
the base gets upside down but I need
this measurement here yeah right the
width of the the surface of the water
okay how will I get that value okay now
just like in the previous question with
the shadow okay I've got some similar
triangles happening here right so let's
call that horizontal distance just
temporarily let's call that X ok what
kind of expression what kind of equation
can I write that relate all of these
things together in similar train was
what would you put down
yeah okay I'm going to go I suppose you
could write a couple of different ways
I'm going to connect the ratio of the
sides and the small triangle with the
ratio of the sides in the big triangle
ok so I'm going to have a little base on
little height right should equal big
base on big height is that ok I've done
anything too dramatic you ok now by the
way this is a rates question it's a
calculus question i'm not going to
bother too much with the proof of
similarity i'm just going to state that
ok right funny now from this equation
what way should i rearrange it to make
things helpful for me because i could
rearrange it in a variety of ways could
know should i make age the subject or x
the subject because i can shoot i'm
going to make extra subject parlor
because I mean I did write it that way i
could have written an upside down right
but the reason why making exit subject
is useful is because that age student
actually want to get rid of it x todo
right when I had this expression for
volume I only want it to be in terms of
h's ok so ordinarily a volume will have
x + H of it but now this slide will let
me get rid of the exes ok so watch now
that i know this i could say volume is
well the volume of a prism is cross
section x depth or leg right so what's
the cross section here to try to go
that's half times base why don't we just
establish the baseball's this
x height that's that isosceles triangle
that's the cross section there okay
we've got even read that that's the
cross section
and then I just have to know how long
with the use which conveniently is just
alpha ok so let's just tie this thing up
I'm going to write it like this twos
cancel ok I know it's not alphabetical
but can anyone see why why have I put my
elbows before my hatred why would I
write it in this way and not have the HS
on the fraction I'm what I've got a
different [ __ ] right so this will make
it a bit easier for me to see number 2
i'm trying to distinguish it to be the
fact that not all printables are created
equal a and L are constants we always
put closes on the front don't we write
be sorry it's also a constant right
whereas H is the variable that I've off
top of course you don't have to write
like that but really I'm trying to make
things as clear as I possibly can ok
good so now i have volume as a function
of each that's what I was after so why
was I after that again so I could
differentiate that's right so that i can
get this guy the case i'm climbing back
up the ladder if that makes sense so i
can work out DB on d h on this basis
right let's just say it's just the power
she'll bring the two down to a el on B
and the power issues by one cool so now
am I ready can I stick this into the
actual original line that I that I want
it I think it can write therefore dho dt
is equal to this is upside down I don't
want this I want its reciprocal so off
the bit that gives me be or to a el
unfortunately I can't keep the edge
upper outer side anymore because it has
to go on the denominator times what's my
DVR duty it's negative C isn't a various
stuff so I've got this
okay now this is how the depth of the
water is changing given any particular
height but I don't want any case I want
a specific one namely when it is beyond
two so i'll say when h equals be on 2
i'll sub it it and it looks like i get
let's see this B will cancel with this
babe and this two will cancel with this
to ya so I'm left with minus C on a L
all right everything else is gone isn't
it ok so my finished I've ever so close
I've done all the work haven't I ok but
what does the question say it says find
the rate at which the water level is for
loop now you know a lot of this stuff
all of this stuff we introduced all of
this stuff right so when I say this the
HRBT the question has no idea what da
chuan continues right it could just as
easily have been what age who knows the
question didn't specify that right
they're all constructs that I've made up
because they're convenient for me so I
can work with this ok I need to provide
the answer back in terms of what the
question was asking ok now that's a few
things I've got a notice number one I've
got our units which I left off because
derivatives don't have news ok so i
should say therefore beyond what's the
writing the water level is falling at
now the first thing i said was units
right but the second thing that I have
to California is well is the water level
falling at this ray
these are falling at that rate and the
answer is no it is not right why not
because they do I haven't introduced a
negative we introduced that way over
here right because the volume is getting
smaller okay now the thing is the
heights also getting smaller but we've
already accounted for that with the word
fall in okay so you do have to be
careful with your signs here right ah
down decreasing increasing it matters
when you consider your dreams right so i
have my negative here right but when i
write this sentence falling takes the
place of the negative okay this is a
much better way to do it by the way they
are the introduction of units and the
accounting for the sign so much better
way to do it in a sentence rather there
to go from this line and say I've read
this before I've seen this before people
say it is okay so units magically appear
and negatives magically disappear just
because we want them to write this is
this is bad don't do that there is no
equality between these two lines but i
can draw this conclusion from this
equation does that make sense it's a
it's a communication thing it's my
illusion it's not the mats but it's um
it's about communication which is very
important so there you go now one last
thing yeah when I first became a maths
teacher and I was a student teacher I
was really amazed by I was like how
could it be to be a math teacher you
should get up and you tell like there's
steps you have to go through so you show
people how to do it and then they just
go replicate the process you went
through its it's easy right and I would
do that and I will give a test and then
students would get questions wrong
questions that I've actually shown them
like specifically had yet and i puzzled
over why that was what i learnt one of
the important things if you're gonna
have to teach anyone this kind of thing
or anything you shouldn't learn this you
can't just show people how to do
something you also have to anticipate
how they're going to do it wrong and
tell them not to okay so i will show you
a kind of error i've seen over and over
again just like this one except
us which is about a misunderstanding of
the way rates of change worked okay and
hopefully will explain why I spent so
much time laboring over this let's come
back a little bit when I started off I
drew this diagram right and basically
what i was trying to do was I just
trying to account for all of the
information that was provided the
question okay put that on there then
start working with it okay now a very
very common thing to do is add these
points here I could say well look I know
what the height is supposed to be right
it's supposed to be beyond to write so
that I can work out what X is supposed
to be and I can sub them in here I can
know what the volume of the water is
supposed to be namely I think if that's
going to be beyond to it looks like
it'll be a lb on for I think I'm in that
event right isn't it ok and they get to
that students get to this point and
anything okay their problems now is
differentiate and then they run into a
brick wall what's the recall you can't
differentiate that and the reason why
you guys could obviously see that's
because they're all constants and that's
obvious to you let me tell you something
it's not obvious to someone who number
one has not done this number two is in a
hurry number three is under exam
pressure and all they see is letters and
numbers right there like sure let's
differentiate with respect to then they
just pick something right and then they
just proceed from there and wonder why
things have gone wrong okay and I've
actually seen a few of you get muddled
up between your clients and your
variables it's all your set off right
but max is not hard it's like whoa well
I could differentiate this well done
guys you know what you want a medal okay
yeah that's not hard but setting it up
properly is so you wouldn't believe a
number of times I've seen students do
this and then just wonder so why I got
this wrong why is it giving me the
answer it's a misunderstanding of the
way rates work and the way all of these
relate to each other